every evening at seven o'clock muneca
till shuts up shop then she and her
husband have their green house paradise
to themselves glass houses like these
normally house flowers fruit or tropical
plants this one has plenty of plant life
too but Monica and Tomas still have also
set up their home here a stone building
and case in glass mama you sensed it
there's a protective shell over you and
that's nice especially when there's rain
hammering down but you can still go out
and enjoy the greenery
come on puts Timo's is cleaner the tills
always get up early breakfast is at 6
a.m. in a setting more like a botanical
garden
sometimes they do get interrupted by
customers coming outside of opening
hours we don't open till 9:00 so there's
no staff here yet
Alton Isaiah but Thomas wouldn't dream
of leaving a customer standing outside
so he waits on her anyway couldn't the
customers know we're always here one
positive thing is we don't have to
travel to work so it saves money as a
custom finished the tills private home
covers 120 square meters of space
doesn't but in Queens so this is the
green part of our living room we have
various things growing here the vine is
further along and it would be if it were
outside here we have black wood bamboo
it's suffered a bit during the winter
but it'll recover what Cesaro in then we
have a four tinium in Evergreen that
many will know from Italy or other
Mediterranean countries and over here is
a variety of a fan palm which grows in
the wild in Italy Italian bites
Monica till has long since got used to
living and working in the same building
oh what's that son - what's our private
living space is protected somehow it is
an open house that's true but it's still
divided up we don't have staff back here
all the time in our private home I like
it's from it happens you can even find a
customer in your living room but not
often in summer temperatures in the
Glass House can rise to over 40 degrees
Celsius so the blinds have to be drawn
your license Amala buys it and somewhat
unbuttoned when it's sunny we normally
leave them a shut or partly shut all day
we have to weigh it up but like now
we're it's a bit cloudy you can leave it
open a bit and then it's quite bearable
Oh flossing done head went to overalls
good job
but what about the work climate what's
it like for staff working right next to
their boss's home mine this is Anitha
it's not always easy we have a very
personal and family like relationship
with each other and with the bosses
which is nice but if the bosses have a
role when we feel it so it's all very
authentic this head booklet and SCSI
life's our attenders aah in 1993 the
tills plucked up the courage to fulfill
their dream they both knew what they
wanted and completely agreed on the plan
they invested several hundred thousand
euros hard work and willingness to take
a risk and it's paid off garden centers
in Germany have a hard time these days
competing with home improvement centers
and discount stores that also sell
plants
Monica till works in distribution and
rarely has to go out to do her shopping
as she is practically everything growing
on her doorstep my guns am hidden I
can't quite avoid buying stuff outside
now and then but we try to use what we
already have here this is much better
quality than anything you get in a
supermarket a supermarket a diva here
fiddles
some of the neighbors complained during
the building phase and found the whole
business idea a little strange that
hasn't changed but the tills don't care
they're living their dream and aren't
quite happy from us come have lunch yeah
and everyday they draw inspiration from
the beauty that surrounds them